today's Jenna's big move into your
apartment and we've gotta get this TV
somehow into my car because I don't like
it's gonna fit in her car
this is the first big purchase that I
bought in Los Angeles what this TV air
mattress here Jana here can't be here it
was actually pretty easy to get and all
things considered considering what it
took to get that to my house and
considering our foreplay MMR left
turned out the whoop
he came with free toilet paper pill free
TV let's see how let's see how this
toilet flushes oh hey I'm breaking the
seal okay oh alright looks great
guys I'm so excited so Tuesday this
Tuesday coming up with October 28 yes
so taking shake is finally opening I'm
so excited I am this was the only way
that I survived college but they cooked
all my food for me it's gonna be right
there and it's right here oh my god you
know how we like our bar opening oh I
feel like we're like this a lot of a
queen I kind of want to have like a
meet-up ish sort of things and happened
to be in Santa Monica on Tuesday sort of
like in the morning ish please come here
3rd Street I want to meet you guys and I
want to milkshake with you so this guy
you're gonna get hit
what look it's gonna be right here no
that's no you're right Lululemon's gonna
be here but I mean it's this is like all
sort of gonna be new holy crap I am so
turnt up
Algie answer the time on Twitter and
Instagram so that's that's how you'll
know holy crap Jun it's right here open
yet
wait what I'll be here for the grand
opening so I'm very excited actually
because they're training the employees
it looks like you are giving like a free
man that's a really good idea this
picture look how nice it looks
we're inside
this is awesome
I can't believe this so beaut in here I
know
we just made it to the pumpkin patch no
guests may be photographed without okay
well that's okay cuz it's just us
welcome to the bones pumpkin pants pony
rides Oh everything is done at 7:00
oh no the jump and pumpkin no the slide
is open till 7:30 but we have to get
some glow sticks like we have to yeah
cool bracelet where's that he's gonna
miss all the fun Jen he's gonna miss at
all oh my gosh look at you guys having
the time of your life that's a chicken
that's a chicken it's a chicken Jenny
just trying to get the shot these are
perfect
yeah look at them so little boy I think
this might be the pumpkin of my dreams
I'm still shooting on 120 frames a
second pumpkin no I don't like it okay
I got a stick this hold on we got to put
the GoPro up how heavy is this yeah I'll
just take a real hefty Punk we're gonna
come I want a t-shirt I can't get out
take credit cards
Oh